[Music]
hello 822 himself et spoke with Bachelor
standout Becca Martinez at the shows
women tell all taping where she revealed
a Bachelor bombshell Becca said that re
sending her home in Italy was not their
final goodbyes the two actually met up
after that dramatic day I just got the
opportunity to talk with him a week
later at his hotel here in LA and it was
filming everything it didn't make the
cut we were just able to talk in for 30
or 45 minutes and just kind of hash out
our relationship and what happened and I
thought it was really good for both of
us so I kinda was able to call him out
and say I don't think you gave me a fair
shot felt like you were looking for a
way out ever since you found out how old
I was because you were afraid of how
strong your feelings worked for me it's
really obvious watching this season that
he opened up to me in a way that he
didn't with other people and we had a
dynamic that I think was so much more
exciting and I don't know there's
something special that we had between us
and so it is kind of hard to watch back
but I think ultimately it's better for
both of us I don't think I don't think
we would necessarily be compatible in
the real world you can hear more from
Becca Ari and the other women when
everyone hashes things out on the women
tell all
airings Sunday February 25th on ABC's
you